the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series that will air in 2022 house of
the dragon
although based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book fire and blood
will not feature targaryens only but
many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
beside the targaryens we'll have
important starks
lannisters baratheons tyrells but also
hightowers
although high towers existed in game of
thrones as well
we had no important high towers in it in
house of the dragon on the other hand
hightowers play the biggest role
alongside targaryens it's otto hightower
the hand of the king
and his daughter ellison hightower the
wife of king viserys targaryen with whom
she has children
that basically started the dance of the
dragons targaryen civil war
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons the targaryen
civil war
which divided the entire kingdom and
launched a huge war that was fought from
129 ac to 131 ac
house of the dragon will start with a
build up towards the dance of the
dragons
in early seasons we'll cover the dance
itself seroto hightower was a knight
from house hightower
who served as hand of the king to three
kings
although two of the kings removed him
from office at various times
he was the younger brother of lord
hightower and the uncle of lore dormund
hightower of old town
his children included ellison hightower
the second queen of king wizards the
first targaryen
and sergey hightower second in command
of the gold cloaks
otto is remembered as a warning that
knowledge is not everything
otto hightower fights or should i say
serves on the behalf of his grandson
aegon ii targaryens against rhaenyra
targaryen
seroto first served as hand of the king
after the death of prince balon
targaryen
the hand and son of king jahiri is the
first targaryen
otto effectively ruled the seven
kingdoms as hand
in the final two years of joharis's
reign while his daughter alice and
hightower nursed the ailing king
oro continued as the hint to jacharys's
grandson
and successor on the throne viserys the
first targaryen
he became a bitter rival of the king's
brother
prince daemon targaryen who had been
named master of coin
otto convinced the king to remove him
from office
and did so again when viserys named
daemon master of loss
he came to regret this however when
daemon was named commander of the city
watch
as this put two thousand men under
daemon's command
and the prince thrived in this new
office odo
feared daemon would become a second meg
or the cruel
if he ever ascended to the iron throne
sharing his fears with his brother
the lord of the hightower thus by this
time
otto wished for princess rhaenyra to
succeed her father
oro's daughter alison became king
viserys's second wife fame 106ac
after the death of queen emma irene in
109 ac
otto was removed as the hand for
hounding viserys to declare alice and
sons the heirs to the iron throne
instead of princess rhaenyra having no
place at court anymore
otto returned to old town a queen's
party known as the greens
the group of powerful lords who were
friends with queen alicent
remained who supported the rights of
fellas and sons
in 120 ac otto returned as hand
after lord lionel strong died when
wizards died in 129 ac
otto played a crucial role in crowning
his eldest grandson as
king aight on the second in defiance of
the last wheel of azaris the first
which specified rhaenyra as the
successor this defiance precipitated the
civil war known as the dance of the
dragons
the dance of the dragons began with otto
serving as hand of the king to aegon ii
targaryen
according to warwile otto ordered the
confinement of lord lyman visbery in the
black selves
sergbane hightower oda's son was named
as the second in command of the gold
clocks
behind sir luther largent the blacks
rhinerate targaryen's faction opposing
aegon's greens
including the battle-tested prince
daemon targaryen
who in the course of his pre-war
adventures had made many foes including
oda
after the death of prince jaehaerys
targaryen at the hands of daemon's
assassins
blood and cheese egg and ordered deaths
of king's landing rat catchers
otto brought a hundred cats to the red
keep
otto reached out to other enemies of the
prince daemon
the kingdom of the three daughters as
allies
they were crucial in breaking the
valyrian blockade in the battle of the
gullet
otto was unsuccessful in gaining an
alliance with cory martel
the prince of dorne king aegon ii told
his grandfather
thrones are one with swords not quills
spill blood not think aegon ii perceived
otto's diplomacy as slothful at a time
when prince daemon had captured
harrenhal and many houses had declared
for the blacks
this led to otto's replacement as the
hand by sir christian cole
the lord commander of the kingsguard
despite the pleading of queen ellison
hightower
otto's daughter and aegon's mother it
was only after his dismissal
the toro's diplomatic efforts bore fruit
just as he had predicted otto was the
first to be beheaded as a traitor by
rhaenyra
after the fall of king's landing in 130
ac
which was not the end of the targaryen
civil war as rhaenyra later loses king's
landing
but it was the end for otto hightower
actor rhys syphen still play a role of
otto hightower in house of the dragon
hbo's official description of the
character
reads the hand of the king who loyally
and faithfully serves both his king and
his realm
as the hand sees it the greatest threat
to the realm is the king's brother
daemon
and his position as heir to the drown
the show will stay true to the books in
this matter
oro's greatest rival in the books was
prince daemon targaryen
and he will also be in the show but most
of the other things however will differ
from the books not only will there be
differences between
the books and the show like it was with
game of thrones
but after reading the book fire and
blood you still don't know how most of
the events really played out
some would think that you could just
read the book fire and blood to know
what will happen in the show
based on that very same book but that's
far from sure
why because fire and blood is not a
conventional novel
it's an imaginary history book and
according to george r martin himself
not very accurate in that because while
firing blood book was written by george
rr martin
it was not written from him as facts but
rather to the perspective of the
citadel's archmaester gildane
who gathered all info and as many
different sources as he could
and used it to write a book about the
targaryen history
some info is fake some info is true some
info is semi true
no one will know for a fact what was
happening in real history until the
house of the dragon airs in 2022
the show unlike the book will contain
truth it will depict what
actually happened not the changed
history fake or semi-true
not what might or might not have
happened fire and blood is a complete
history of house targaryen written by
george rr martin from the perspective of
archmaester gildane
who wrote it many decades after the
events took place
sure most of the main events such as
battles and deaths probably did happen
but as gildane says it in the books the
full truth about what happened behind
closed doors
in the privacy of stairwells council
rooms and bed chambers he does not fully
know
and he turns to many different sources
which usually differ from one another
he looks into the course of chronicles
laid down by grand maester runcider and
his successors
and many court documents as well gildane
looks into accounts written
decades later by children and
grandchildren of those caught up in the
events of these times
while they are undoubtedly of use so
much time has passed between the event
and the recording that many confusions
and contradictions have inevitably crept
in
unfortunately this is also true for
gildan's two accounts
by first hand observers that have come
down to him
septon eustace who served in the royal
sept in the red keep
during much of this time and spent much
time as a confident and confessor to
king viserys and his queens
his account is biased favoring aegon
over rhaenyra
the second account is based upon a
verbal account of the court full
mushroom
who was present at court for all of them
for king viserys princess
and queen rhaenyra and both king aegons
the second and the third during his
reign
king balor the first targaryen had
mushroom's book burned on account of its
scandalous content
there are several main sources for
historical information on the dance of
the dragons
which are frequently at odds with each
other gildan also used this source
written by grand maestro while
who had served king aegon ii targaryen
on his council
and was arrested by the forces of queen
rhaenyra targaryen
when she took the city orwell wrote his
account while locked away in the black
cells
uncertain about whether or not he would
survive the war
he attempted to paint himself in the
best light possible
grain maester monkens the dance of the
dragons said true telling was based on
orwell's account
using all these sources which often
differ from one another
archmaester gildan wrote his work fire
and blood his work about the history of
house targaryen
this format brings up martin's major
thematic point about the uncertainty of
memory
and history being written by winners
neither side
truly won the war and decades after the
war both sides wrote
their own biased history books trying to
put their actions in a better light
thus history is written by the greens
depicted ii
in good light and rhaenyra in a bad
light
on the other hand histories written by
the blacks do the opposite
we'll know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show airs
and that's why you cannot just read the
book fire and blood and think you would
know what actually happened or what will
happen on the show
books are written by archmaester decades
and decades after the events took place
using many sources that in most cases
are very different from each other and
most of them are biased as well
what we can tell you for a fact is that
house of the dragon starts filming in
around 3 weeks
and will air in 2022 on hbo we can also
tell you that otto hightower will play a
huge role
he's the grandfather of aegon ii and he
alongside his daughter queen ellison
starred targaryen sybil moore the war
began when king viserys the first died
started by the greens otto and ellis and
hightower
among others by disobeying king
viserys's orders of crowning rhaenyra
and instead crowning aegon as the new
king of westeros
the same day that viserys the first died
aegon the second's followers the green
stage daku
and he was soon crowned in king's
landing rhaenyra as the princess of
dragonstone had her power base on
dragonstone island
where she responded by being crowned
queen by daemon and declaring aegon a
traitor
does the targaryen civil war begin thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs
up and i hope to see you in the next one
peace